good morning believe nation today's
message is focused on the journey open
to you Jessie J I don't ever disregard
the fact that however hard you work you
know it doesn't always guarantee it's
gonna happen and that's the thing that
you have to just believe if you don't
believe in you no one else will even
bother to look at you and I shoved
myself around any open mics any gigs and
exactly an amount of stuff I've probably
done even up to now 80 90 % of all my
gigs for free surround yourself with
people that you can trust
surround us other people that let me be
you don't ever comes like compromise but
don't ever you know lose what makes you
you right from the heart stay happy and
always remember there's always someone
worse afternoon
and there's always someone that's
working lighter than you as well when
you're asleep there's someone roughed in
and that's what you have to remember as
well that for every 10 CDs you send off
there's someone sending over on 400 just
get yourself out there's much you can
and film everything
one thing I've learned that I'm glad
that I did footage from years ago that
people say to me oh you you've copied so
insane you've done you've done that I'm
like go on YouTube new fighters go still
the same songs are the same haircut it's
just you gotta have fun as well write it
down make sure you write down take
pictures and make sure it's a journey
and the journey is way more important
than where you end where you end up one
of the most popular questions I get
asked is how will I know when I've
reached 1 billion entrepreneurs
my big goal my big vision mission what I
want to do I want to reach a billion
entrepreneurs I want to know that I'm
having that kind of impact and put out
content and create amazing things for a
ton of entrepreneurs and I get people
asking well how will you know when you
hit a billion entrepreneurs or I don't
think there's even a billion
entrepreneurs in the world and you're
missing the point I don't actually have
a way to track if I'm hitting a billion
entrepreneurs and I don't care about it
because I'm not focused on the goal I'm
focused on the journey
what it does is make sure that it aligns
me to think about big projects and so
anything that I'm spending significant
time on I want to make sure has the
ability to reach a lot of people so I'm
making youtube videos because it can
spread and reach a lot of people when I
started to write my book I wanted to do
it with a big publisher not just
self-published even though
self-publishing can make me a lot more
money I want the big publisher because I
wanted to try to get more reach it's the
reason why I don't do business coaching
and one-on-one consulting although it
could be really meaningful and great to
have the one-on-one connection I want to
do things on a bigger scale and so what
that big goal allows me to do is focus
my efforts on the right projects but I
don't actually care about hitting a
billion entrepreneurs just like if I say
my next goal on the YouTube channels I
want to hit a million subscribers it's
amazing it's great you know you get a
play button we might have you know
another celebration but as soon as I hit
a goal
I don't really celebrate I feel like I
need to celebrate more because my team
it's a good thing to do kind of for
team-building but as soon as I hit a
goal I'm on to the next thing I don't
take time to celebrate because the work
is the celebration for me I want to work
more I want to get better I want to
continue to improve hitting a goal and
then saying that's it is death for me
and for a lot of people when you hit a
goal it actually be depressing you know
when I sold my first business it was 22
years old it was a great high great I
sold the company but then the next day I
had nothing to do like what do I weren't
supposed to do I got I'd have nothing to
go to in the morning and that's a great
problem to have and not something I'm
complaining about but still a problem
like when you hit a goal and you don't
know what you're gonna do next it's
depressing you don't know what to do
every day and when you don't have a plan
for what to do every day it can really
drag you down and so I think in doing
all these profiles of different famous
entrepreneurs people have had massive
success yes it can be great to have a
big goal it can be great to win an award
or hit a revenue target or lend that big
customer or whatever it is go IPO sell
your company have some big goal what if
the goal is the only thing
driving you it's gonna be really hard to
make it were the most successful people
the journey is the reward the journey of
creating something and marketing it and
you're getting better at it and seeing
the impact that is the work that is the
goal that is the joy that is the
excitement that is where you derive your
most pleasure from not just about
hitting some target and so it really
challenge you to look at your life your
business think about what your goals are
I love setting goals because when you
set a goal for me the most important
part of it is that it starts to align
your actions to achieve that goal and
it's not just about hitting the goal
it's about those actions those actions
are what's gonna serve me to be the best
version of me to allow me to have the
big impact that I want to have and so
look at your schedule look at what
you're doing every day look at your
day-in day-out in your business and in
your life do you enjoy the journey for
me getting married as an example I
didn't really care about the wedding day
Nina may not be too happy about that but
she knows I don't really care about the
wedding it's just another day like for
me the excitement the energy the joy is
in the marriage it's the everyday it's
the journey not just one day right when
you have a kid it's not just about the
kid being born and having the goal to
have a kid great amazing you know I've
hated almost eight years old that was an
amazing day but it's the it's journey
it's the day-to-day it's the parenting
it's every day connecting that's where
you grow and that's what you need to
enjoy if all you're waiting for as a
parent is for your kid to move out go to
college get a job if all you're waiting
for in your marriage is to hit that
ten-year anniversary your 25-year
anniversary your two-year anniversary or
whatever it it's like you're missing out
the goal is not as important as the
process to get there the goal helps you
align yourself so your actions help you
be the best version of you I'm not the
guy says no goals goals are important I
love having goals I set goals to myself
all the
but much more important than the goal is
the journey so the question today I love
your input what do you guys think is the
goal more important is the journey more
important share your thoughts give some
more context I'd love to hear what's on
your mind share it down the comments
below and we'll join in the conversation
I also want to give a quick shout it's a
gourd is Monde gourd thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word it really really really really
means a lot to me and I hope you're
enjoying it thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso
[Music]